hey guys before we get into this episode
we wanted to ask you to help us out with
something we need you to go over to pod
survey comm slash biscuits and fill out
a quick anonymous survey for us we're
able to provide ear biscuits to you for
free because of our sponsors but it's
important to us that those sponsors be
things that you actually care about and
this survey helps make that happen at
pod survey comm slash biscuits you'll
find a short anonymous survey it'll take
no more than five minutes and it's
really helpful to us your answers will
help match our show with advertisers
that best fit the sensibilities of our
podcast and its listeners that's you
when you complete the survey you'll be
entered into an ongoing monthly raffle
to win a $100 Amazon gift card gift card
guard card card
and we promise we will not share your
email address we won't send you an email
unless you win but you got to go to pod
survey comm slash biscuits to take the
survey listen I mean I don't want you to
do it for the Amazon gift card I want
you to do it because you like us and
we're just really saying pretty please
but hey the gift card it might happen so
pod survey calm slash biscuits to take
our survey and a chance to win $100
Amazon gift card thanks welcome to ear
biscuits I'm link and I'm Rhett joining
us today at the round table of dim
lighting as motivational speaker
best-selling author and youtuber the
very inspiring Josh Sundquist okay
Josh's journey began at age 9 well I
guess it began it ain't zero yeah but
you know the the big story began at age
9 when he was diagnosed with a rare form
of bone cancer Ewing's sarcoma and he
was given a 50% chance to live he spent
a year on chemotherapy treatments and
his left leg was amputated but he didn't
let that slow him down he went on to
become a member of the US Paralympic Ski
Team as well as the u.s. amputee soccer
team I mean this guy's basically
excelled at everything he's tried
including writing speaking and creating
original Halloween costumes that take
special advantage of having one leg you
better believe we talked to him about
that Josh also has a popular YouTube
channel where he uploads
and collaborations his first big video
was a rap song called the amputee rap so
let me tell you what it's like to walk a
while
in my shoes I got one leg but a smile on
my face you misspelled too if you have
my parking space my leg is cut off way
up at the hip but using these crutches
I've run pretty quick he's also spoken
in person believe it or not in person
that still happens I believe thousands
of people all over the nation using is
engaging storytelling ability how many
of you that are like me in order to save
money when you go into movies you like
to smuggle food in your pockets anyone
do this so I'm with my friends out front
this movie theater we're saying the
parking lot right we're putting small
candy items in our pockets my friend
pulls out of the trunk of the car a two
liter of coca-cola classic this two
liter right and we're like really this
is not gonna fit in anyone's pockets I
do not understand what you're thinking
but then I think of this brilliant idea
you ready for this because my friend is
wearing sweatpants I am wearing shorts
so we switch I put on his sweatpants I
take the Tulear I put it inside of the
left pant leg I tie a knot underneath so
it hangs there looks like my leg is cut
off like down here and then I look down
and the 2-litre is just swinging all
around and there's this security guard
standing there looking at me right and I
can tell that he wants to say something
but let's be honest with ourselves like
what is he going to say like sir I
noticed that there is a problem with
your leg
[Applause]
you are correct I do not have one we
cover many topics for Josh including the
moving back story of him losing his leg
the hilarious experiences from his new
book we should hang out sometime that's
the name of the book I'm not coming even
though I do like I would like to hang
out with you talking a mean book I'm
talking we're hanging out right now I'm
not looking at you out when I look into
space when were you looking at the
people that's when I'm talking to
biscuit ear syska tears okay gotcha we I
think we we shall exact ly we should
write a book called we should hang out
with
hey that's a good idea okay mr. Joshi at
least write a book he can write before
word has inspired us to write a book
especially when he talks he shares all
the hilarious stories basically he
tracked down all of the girls that he
dated and tried to find out what went
wrong so yeah yeah that was pretty good
we also explored the crazy questions
he's been asked over the years about
having one leg now Josh he's an amazing
example of someone who has been making a
living at something they're passionate
about and also good at but that's not an
easy thing to do it's not easy to figure
out how to get started that's why the
guys at roadtrip nation have put
together a book called road map no this
is not the Atlas making a big comeback I
can't say I wasn't a little disappointed
that the Atlas is not even going to come
back because very large road maps or
we're a very important part of the trunk
in my dad's car oh I I remember that or
behind the seat or the top of the
dashboard yeah I remember that
no the tagline of this book is to get it
together guide for figuring out what to
do with your life don't you want to know
what to do with your life you can order
it at the only book you need dot-com
well that's bold the only book you need
comp yeah the roadtrip nation guys
traveled the world talking to all kinds
of amazing people who have been a
success in doing something they love
that includes marvel's chief creative
officer professional chefs sports
journalists entrepreneurs and beyond
roadmaps fill with self-discovery
activities and the wisdom gleaned from
all these people so you can figure out
how to start following your passion and
pay the bills y'all I think this is
important I mean if I could go back and
I had this URL the only book you need
com available to me I would have gone
there I'm not knocking our guidance
counselor but I'm kind of knocking our
high school guidance I don't even
remember who the guidance counselor was
we have engineering degrees people I
mean if you knew it was as simple as
going we followed no road map the only
book you need Cobb all right now on to
the biscuit
tell us about your Halloween costumes
like we're nowhere near Halloween but
something tells me that you've been
thinking about it constantly year round
based on your track record
yeah it's become a big thing I love it
yeah thank you but yeah it's it's a
weird thing in that it's so many ways
one thing like as a kid like I grew up
in a really conservative religious home
okay we didn't celebrate Halloween at
all I'm the only braided harvest yeah
yeah we'd have these yeah the pseudo
like harvest festivals or whatever is
Festival I'm loose or we'd celebrate the
Reformation weirdly information day yeah
exactly like yeah Martin Luther like but
would you do trunk-or-treat in like the
parking lot of the church no I don't eat
what is that they do that now where they
bring all the insulated families into
the whole album to go leave the church
and go into the parking lot on Halloween
night and then they go around to the
trunks of cars that the church members
have parked and then they give out candy
out of the trunk of the car huh yeah and
then they go around the neighborhood and
they nail the knife I've theses on the
doors of everyone if we were at home I
mean we literally like lock the doors
turned all the lights off so that like
no one would come to our door because my
parents like thought if we gave out
candy
we were we were like contributing to the
devil oh yeah you're a part of the
problem yeah so we're you ever tricked
because of that right yeah like people
were like oh you guys don't give out
candy here's an egg on your no I think
people just just you know we take it
actually that did happen once I don't
know if it was in relation to Halloween
oh it was you but now did you bring that
up it very well could have been
retribution from the neighborhood yeah
that's what it was for us laughs you've
not egged not contributing to the sugar
but yeah so I never really even wore any
Halloween costumes until college and
perhaps appropriately given the
religious background my first Halloween
costume I dressed as the Holy Ghost I
just literally just wore sheet over my
butt I just put on a sheet look that was
how it was like the worst
whoever it was like so little work what
made your ghost holy though well it was
always on the sheets and no it was
wouldn't even do that I guess I was just
yeah it was it was I'm not going to
defend the console I will say though
that me and to my friends were in on it
and so we were the Holy Trinity I had a
friend who at the time had really long
hair and wore a robe so obviously he was
Jesus and then my other friend had like
a long white beard or a fake beard and
so he was God the Father you didn't send
this picture to mom and dad no yeah
they're probably listening this podcast
and very upset right now but to
sacrilege but you didn't need just one
leg for that no yeah yeah later yes like
that way so you needed no legs exactly
technically I had it was a problem that
I was walking I should have just been
floating around right but I didn't have
the the technological know-how for that
so yeah it was it was only sort of later
that that I had any sort of amputee
related one and it was the first time I
did one it was after college and that
was when I did a partially eaten
gingerbread man and and it wasn't even
it was it was really kind of a lazy
thing it wasn't like I was like man what
would be like a clever amputee costume I
was it was like the last minute and I
think it was from like Shrek you know
yeah I was like my gumdrop buttons or
whatever and and so I literally just
bought a normal gingerbread man costume
and just cut the leg off and I was like
boom done this is my costume and that
drastically increased the quality of
that copy did you know did you have any
indication that okay I'm surely I'm
gonna put this online and did you know
no because this was in 2011 and so it
was this was like pre like kind of
BuzzFeed you know the concept of like
viral images was very new and in fact
like I the only place I posted it was
the now defunct site dailybooth you guys
remember daily yeah yeah yes like that's
the only record I have of the picture is
actually daily booth so it's like super
grainy it was on a web cam of course but
yeah so I didn't it didn't occur to me
that it was gonna be a popular thing
online but but like I put it on
dailybooth and it was like all sudden
all these people were texting me you
know like I love your costume it's
amazing
and but it still wasn't a theist it
wasn't a viral thing or anything but
yeah I went to parties and most like the
main reaction actually was not so much
like that's an amazing costume it was
like where did you hide your leg this is
an incredible illusion you've created
and I have crutches like why do you
think I own titanium one-piece crutches
like that I bought for this costume
right you're a high roller yeah that's
this is this is how I go with my
Halloween costume so yeah and so it
wasn't following up next year with no so
it still didn't occur to me like because
again it wasn't like a viral thing and
it wasn't uh okay you know yeah just
never occurred to me like oh but it did
eventually right so that yeah so the
next year I just I was Angry Birds with
my friend you know it was fine and then
the year after that my girlfriend at the
time now fiance suggested hey like you
should be the leg lamp from a Christmas
story
oh well yeah and I was and and I looked
online and some amputees had like done
that before okay but they hadn't done a
like a real good job no offense if
you're one of them listening right now
but I saw them I was like I think I can
do way better and like really go all out
so I got like shaved my leg got fishnet
stockings got an actual lampshade and
like lit it up from the inside with a
battery pack so it was like a portable
walking lampshade and yeah and and and
that one when I made it I was like I bet
people online more like this because
this is done by then 2013 so like at
that point you know images online we're
like a thing right and so yeah so
basically a friend of a friend posted it
on reddit and then it just it like blew
up from there and then people went back
and like somehow found my dailybooth oh
this is just look look at this thing he
did before like and then and that's when
it became like a thing so then the but
then the bar started to raise what was
after that yeah so then exactly so then
then it was like clearly oh this is a
thing you've got to do now people like
think I do this every year and I have
expectations and so yeah yeah so then I
felt pressure and so and I thought well
like the Halloween the the costume with
the leg lamp was like so popular because
it brought back childhood memories for
people you know like Christmas
story and all like fragile a and all you
know all those things so I was like
there's no way anything will ever be
like that but you know I'll try you know
see what I come up with and so the next
year I this one just happened I just was
that like a zoo once and I saw a
flamingo and I was like you know that
looks kind of like me if I'm doing a
crutch handstand and it was just a weird
thing it was just like I don't know just
because I give you know I do like funny
speeches about having one leg a lot of
my humor on YouTube is about amputee
stuff like I'm just always looking at
that stuff and and I it was funny
because I told a lot of people to
costume how did I'm I was like I think
I'm gonna be a pink flamingo and
everyone assumes of course cuz flamingos
stand on one leg you know no idea just
wait this is gonna blow your mind so
yeah so I got like a pink spandex suit
and very flattering oh yes it was you
got you mean you didn't already have one
yeah I pulled out my peak spandex suit
yes from the closet where I keep all of
my onesie spandex uniforms and and yeah
I you should say that my assistant Lisa
who is a huge fan of you guys in your
show helps me with these she's very
crafty and she like helps me build these
things because it takes a lot like
conceptual thinking of like how we're
gonna actually make this and then so and
then I we got like a elf shoe which she
painted like a flamingo head on and and
then yeah I just do its I mean you'd
have to it's it's weird and to describe
in podcast it's you have to see it right
like to get it so I guess Google Josh
Sundquist Halloween costume but you guys
know I'll come up the to trot trucks
crutches are right leg right the
flamingo and when you lean your head
forward and go into a pants like a half
handstand right so it's like my head is
the flamingo's but and then my leg
becomes like the neck and my my foot is
like the actual the head and it has like
these it's very convincing very
convinced yeah it's pretty like and I
can't really like I can balance in like
an actual handstand on my crutches but
not in that specific position and it's
actually like off balance so it was like
a flamingo in motion yeah
it was like me and my girlfriend we just
did like a bunch of shots you know with
just like in burst mode and and just
like wit kept and we had like one that
was just like this is uncanny it looks
so flamingo you know and we did it we
even went to the zoo too because I just
thought it would be amusing to like do
it right beside the flamingos and it
would be yes and but that was weird
walking around the zoo in a pink
flamingo or like a pink leotard has an
upside-down flamingo yeah I'm walking on
its head yeah so they've done one more
since yeah yeah so then the flamingo is
just huge yeah it was yeah so it's just
like every year's like more and more
pressure and like people like he wins
Halloween again and and so yeah so then
this year I did a foosball player and it
was like particularly sort of meaningful
to me and the reason I thought it was
cool is because this year I had the
opportunity to make the u.s. amputee
soccer team right and which was cool
because like before I lost my leg when I
was a kid I played soccer and I hadn't
really like played it since I became an
amputee and now there's just like
amputee soccer sport out there and like
the US team is finally a good enough
that we went to the World Cup this year
so it was like a cool cool like
personally meaningful thing to me to me
like I'm gonna actually dress like as a
semi soccer player in a foosball
position and so yeah this one was
actually really difficult to construct
because we really wanted to have the
illusion of me floating and right so and
to look like because it's easy to like
do a Photoshop things but I wanted to be
like what you see is the actual photo
taken right so we like rented out an
entire like indoor soccer arena because
that has that look of a foosball you
know thing has them like the walls the
walls that sort of drop back and then we
got like a ballet bar and and built
around that like reflective material to
look like a you know like the spinning
bar or whatever right and then and did
me up all and like all this like paint
to make me look shiny and plastic and
just like oh yeah that's great yeah
great that keeps getting raised yeah
exactly so now it's like you've got the
thing on your foot that looks like the
big yeah exactly right yeah then this we
had just like the big box and so and I
just sort of like sat and balanced there
on that boat it's funny when it because
when I saw that
I thought oh well you know this has been
so popular now there's there's some
sponsor that's that's paying for Josh to
do is Halloween photo or did you just
say I know I'm because it was so like
over-the-top and produced or you know
I've taken upon myself that I'm just
going to make this happen every single
year yeah I did well so I I sort of
tried and failed semi failed at doing
like a
IndieGoGo okay so I put it up and it was
like as people do when you do IndieGoGo
and such a lot of people were like what
like why why would we give you money
like people on the internet just want my
money because it's awesome yeah so so a
lot of people did give money towards it
but I but like I honestly put it up
thinking like people will think this is
cool and fun like I'm happy to pay for
it myself right so and I got some money
but I paid for most of myself it was
pretty expensive pretty expensive but
like yeah because I hired like a real
photographer we had like all the lights
up and everything right um but to me
it's uh it's a great investment because
people love it and it's it's like it
honestly is a part of like the business
of what I do you know like I make my
living mostly as a motivational speaker
and a lot of people you know like when
they contacted me to speak they're like
we love your Halloween costumes you know
like the costumes sort of capture the
message of what I'm gonna share on stage
and so it's like it's really kind of the
best possible advertising I could do is
to like invest in a really great costume
and we should save it those are at the
top of your YouTube channel even yeah so
if you go there to enjoy your content
you can see them that's the easy way
just to see them all into a collage yeah
they're all that warrants yep take us
back let's go I would love to get your
story from from the beginning which I'm
sure you've told many times but I'd like
to piece it all together
so like as a child kind of you yeah so
yeah like I said I was uh when I went
out to Lex as a kid I was reeling to
soccer and when I was nine as when I
started having a lot of pain and it was
actually this
I guess sort of poignant in and that the
like literally the same week that I was
gonna try out for my first travel soccer
team was the week that I had a biopsy
where they found cancer because I'd been
having a lot of pain and whatnot and so
they had to open me up and it was yeah
it was a really aggressive form of
cancer at a 50% chance to live yeah so
it was very serious I mean a nine year
old yes I mean you remember getting that
news just is the doctor talking to you
is the doctor talking to your your
parent yeah so my parents told me yeah
you know there's an interesting thing in
kids around that age parents sort of
make the call as to how much information
they want to share with a child I was
old enough that my parents chose to tell
me everything and I'm glad they did but
there it was it's a kind of it's it's a
weird thing because like you know they
told me like my parents told me they're
you know it was almost like like a Santa
Claus thing you know like oh but like
don't tell the other kids because like
they were like you know not other kids
at the hospital might not know how sick
they are so like don't tell them that
they have cancer because they might not
actually know you know and then they
told you like your chances of survival
they went there - yeah and and in that
moment that was like good news to me
because like as a nine-year-old the only
thing I knew about cancer was my
grandfather had died of it and so to me
you know I didn't it wasn't even
I wasn't even cognizant that there could
be ways to treat it or survival so like
I immediately thought I've cancer I'm
gonna die so actually it was in
retrospect and sort of ironically out
like good news that they're like no
actually the doctors of tolis your kind
of cancer has a 50% chance of survival
which of course is still very low so
yeah so I started chemotherapy
treatments I I had a tumor in my leg in
my femur which is like the bone from
your knee to your hip and after about
three months the tumor was still the
same size so something had to be sort of
done surgically and there's like a lot
of different operations besides
amputation that are possible like you
can take out the bone and put it in a
like a metal rod or a cadaver bone like
all kinds of wild stuff
but the amputation was just like by far
the best chance of survival and it's
also if you if you try to do what's
called a limb salvage operation it's the
your leg is very fragile and so to me it
was like I would you know as a
athletically oriented child I was like
well yeah okay so having one leg it's
gonna be harder to do stuff but I'm not
gonna be fragile per se you know I can
do like whatever I'm able to do
physically whatever I can figure out how
to do with your leg like the doctors not
gonna be like no no you could break you
know if you do that sport right so so
yeah and so you you helped make that
yeah yeah yeah it was me and my parents
we met with like a lot of doctors got a
lot of opinions met with like amputees
yeah I mean obviously that was a huge
decision but yeah I felt very much like
it was a joint decision between my
parents and I and I'm really grateful
that you know that they involved me with
that right because I could see a child
who who wasn't involved looking back
later and being like my parents chose
this for me you know this life right
where as I look back and say like this
is the life I chose yeah so yeah so I
lost my leg I mean obviously that's a
pretty like traumatic thing and yeah I
mean yeah what do you remember about
that about the you know before the
procedure yeah I guess probably the most
sort of notable memories about that were
yeah right right before you know I mean
I was really sad like especially you
know in the weeks leading up to it
really sad like I cried myself to sleep
this is loveable sad I remember you know
sitting in the the operating or not the
operating room sort of the waiting room
you know where you you get prepped or
wait or whatever before you go back for
the operation and and and yeah I guess
the best way I can describe it is you
guys are old enough and probably so your
listeners are old enough that you know
you've you've you've had someone that
you know died suddenly at some point and
they're sort of this like almost eerie
feeling of disbelief like we were like
no no like I just talked to him or her
last week or whatever and that's that's
how it felt like it was this idea like
I'm gonna be put to sleep and then I'm
gonna wake up and this leg is you know
like it's not gonna be there
and yeah it was just was such a strange
feeling and the doctor nurse came in and
I hadn't walked for three months because
you know that my life was very fragile I
had a brace on it I wasn't supposed to
put any weight on it but the doctor and
a nurse came in and they had a
wheelchair like to bring me back to the
operating room and looking back I'm not
sure exactly why I I made this decision
but I guess I guess I realized well like
what's the worst thing that could happen
like I could break my leg from walking
and so I was like you know actually like
I don't want to use a wheelchair like
I'm gonna walk because this is like this
is my last chance to walk and so yeah so
I walked back to the operating room and
the next memory I had was was waking up
and just having a horrible phantom limb
pain and really yeah and and in phantom
limb pain it's just you know and of
course they had told me about it ahead
of time warned me but I mean it's just
such a strange thing like you can't even
a mat like you can't be prepared for it
like I woke up and and I first I felt
like oh they didn't even amputate my leg
cuz I could feel and it was just like
throbbing and pain and it was in this
like really weird position like it was
like sticking straight in the air and
then like I opened my eyes and it's like
it's not there yeah it's it's so phantom
limb pain it's just it's so wild and I
still think it's like it's really
fascinating just like neurologically but
for a while it was like pretty
debilitating pain wise but I guess you
know you sort of you're your brain is
hardwired to have what's called
proprioception which is like the sense
of your body in space so you know you
could lose any part of your body a
finger a nose in the air or whatever and
you'll still feel it like in your brain
and and you can have pain in it and
that's what what the phantom limb pain
is so yeah so I went through that for a
while but you know I felt like I went
through a lot of the grieving beforehand
and and afterwards I was you know I and
I don't want to like take credit for it
myself I think I had like tremendously
supportive parents and friends and
family you know who would raise me well
and had really like rallied behind me
but I like I
really bounce back I think a lot quicker
than people were expecting and maybe
then that you know then some people
perhaps ever do you know with an
amputation so yeah I mean after like 2
or 3 days after the amputation I was
like running on my crutches like around
the hospital like literally like running
was it an expression of your support
structure alone it was it also the type
of person that you were was it an active
decision that you remember making that
I'm going to run around on these
crutches and I'm you know what were the
components of recovery for you you were
to be accelerated like that yeah I think
that's an insightful question and you
know I think it's it's it's a little bit
of all of that right it's it's having
parent you know like great support
structure it's having like taking
gymnastics as a child so I was like
pretty agile and had really good balance
really quickly and I think there was a
decision element to I think you know at
that point I still had another nine
months of chemotherapy in front of me
you know my life was still on the line
so I think there was also an element of
it of to me thinking like I don't know
how much longer my life is gonna be so
like yes I have one leg but I'm gonna
try and make the best of it whatever
that means
so there was still cancer in your body
at that time it just yeah I mean that
yeah the weird thing about you know
having an amputation is you don't it
like yes that got rid of what's known to
be the cancer but you know maybe there's
like a really small amount of cancer
like in your lungs or you know it's
metastasized somewhere else
so you still go through the whole like
the original protocol of chemotherapy
which was a year so I was on it for for
another nine months so like a year in
total so yeah it was a lot chemotherapy
about a hundred nights I spent in the
hospital oh well no and it was three
years before you were declared free and
clear of cancer right that's right yeah
so three years because most cancer you
are declared cured after five years but
it just depends on the type of cancer
mine is very aggressive and so if it
hasn't come back in three years that's
when they say you're cured which is like
just the best feeling ever
you know that's something that I look
back on and think of you know those
those times went in when you're in
remission in that period in between and
you know you go in for tests every three
months or every six months and it's just
like has the cancer come back right now
and because if the cancer comes back
it's your chances of survival are very
low so you know those were those were
scary years listen what's your sense of
humor that we see now in all of your
work something that was present then
even from that young of an age or
something that developed later yeah
that's a great question some of both you
know I don't I it wasn't I
it took it took many years I think to
become as comfortable with being an
amputee as I am now you know like I wore
a prosthesis until halfway through
college when I started high school I was
home-schooled until high school and so
when I started high school is very
worried you know just if that people
would even find out I was an amputee so
I think there was a much greater sense
of self-consciousness there but at the
same time really early on I think humor
was actually a way of sort of dealing
with it uh yeah I mean like therefore
you know yeah right after I got fitted
with a prosthesis that yeah this is kind
of that maybe the first the first window
into like what he Murr could do and how
it could help me cope I was in the
hospital for a chemotherapy treatment
and there was I was treated at a
teaching hospital so a medical student
was examining me and just doing like a
physical taking my vitals and such and
he was like taking my pulse and and and
finally my mom was like Josh my parents
called me Joshua of course my given name
but she's like yeah Joshua like has a
prosthesis now and you are trying to
take a pulse from it and you found this
funny yeah exactly yeah and so it was
like yeah and I which I thought it was
just hilarious instead yeah yeah I mean
and yes I mean that was probably yeah
just a month or six weeks after my
mutation and I think that looking back
that was the first like really funny
thing that happened I was like that's
really funny
and I think after that I started looking
more and more for like okay yeah like
obviously you know I'm not like
sometimes people will come up to me
after a speech or write in the comments
a video you're there like man like your
jokes about being an amputee or so like
so funny like it makes me kind of want
to be an amputee you know but they'll
always preface it with something like
you know like don't take this the wrong
way all right yeah right where do you
know like okay or like no offense yeah
right no offense here but I'm like okay
Wow yeah that is you totally got the
wrong message like I do not like suggest
being an amputee well that's a good
that's your perspective is is so
compelling that that's the effect that
it has on yeah I guess they some of
people it's interesting cuz you were
nine when the surgery happened link
you've got a nine-year-old son I've got
a ten-year-old son so we've got like
kids in that age range yeah and I'm
thinking about like that happening and
then making that adjustment wait just
what what about socially mmm in those
formative years you're becoming a
teenager and moving into high school
like how did the fact that you're an
amputee at that point play into you know
I interact with other kids yeah I know
it was really really terrifying at first
you know it's it's you know it's weird
now like 20 years later because it's
like obviously it's it's just a part of
me it's not a big deal anymore but yeah
and and in that sense I think you know
my parents played a really great role in
you know a lot of times you hear people
with with disabilities you know who who
have psychologically adjusted well we'll
talk about how like you know my parents
never treated me any differently you
know they you know like that's the key
thing and I and I don't think they quite
mean that literally because I think you
do have to treat someone according to
their his or her own needs like of
course you treat each of your kids a
little differently not that you're like
showing favoritism to them but like each
of your kids are individual yeah they
have their own personality their
problems their own hopes etc so you know
I think that my parents you know there
were times you know really early on yet
where I was I was pretty nervous too
like for example like to go to go to
like the swimming pool you know and they
found like a friend of ours who but I
wanted to like swim I wanted to try it
you know and so they found like a friend
of ours who like how to pool at their
house so I didn't have to go like a
public pool and you know I had gone to
like summer camp before I lost my leg
but I was really scared to go back and
and so they like basically like bribed
me and and I was in retrospect a very
easily bribed considering like how
scared I was of summer camp but they
were like if you go to summer camp we
will give you 25 dollars that you can
spend at the snack shop at can't oh yeah
and I was like twenty-five dollars of
ice cream that is amazing so
game-changer yeah yeah yeah and did it
work out yeah and it was awesome but it
but you know it was like it was like
stuff like that like otherwise without
that ice cream like there was no like it
seems so so worth it it seems so silly
but like that really was like a deciding
factor of me going and I'm so glad I did
you know because then it was like that
was when I started to get exposure to
other people because of course I was in
a unique situation being homeschooled
like I wasn't I wasn't immediately
thrust into an environment with like
hundreds of kids at once I had like a
social network but my social network was
like my church and my homeschool group
which was like a pretty small group and
a very close-knit group and so in that
sense I was I was lucky to have friends
who were I think very mature and came
from like homes where parents were like
giving them like sort of like you know
don't you know like josh is still like a
normal person like treat him as such the
other thing I'm sure there are many
milestones but how did you get to become
a motivational speaker yeah so I started
giving the first time I was like giving
talks was right around that time when I
was like nine ten years old
really yeah doing at that time not like
what I do now but they were like
raising speeches from my hospital so you
know I was like sort of like the poster
child to be like for the donors to be
like look the hospital is helping me
survive
you should give my name here's a funny
story about a resident that you know who
thought I had you know who tried to take
a pulse from my leg which in retrospect
is like the worst possible story yes
your hospital is like about practice
suit waiting to happen
give it money but yeah so that was the
first time I sort of in front of
audiences and you know started to grow
comfortable with that and then when I
was 15 years old and by that time in in
a public school a motivational speaker
came to my high school and I just like
saw you know his speech and just thought
like this is the coolest thing ever and
ironically you know I I was really I was
really interested in doing it but I was
really afraid because I was like oh you
know I think it'd be a motivational
speaker you have to have like a really
interesting life story and I don't have
one which is okay yeah I know it's like
looking back it's like what but like at
the time it's just like it just didn't
occur to me that that my life was that
interesting and so my early speeches
were terrible because number one they
were like super like didactic and just
it was like I listen to other
motivational speakers and tried to be
like Tony Robbins you know so I'd get up
and be like you must have goals and like
I'm so awesome and you should be like me
and and they were they were just so bad
and and nobody paid attention and then
gradually over time I realized the time
that people were paying attention was in
you know the short moments when I might
have an anecdote about myself or what
had happened to my leg or a cancer or
whatever and then gradually then I
realized oh wait I actually do have a
story and it's a story that people are
really interested in and that people
naturally you naturally create a
metaphor right like most audiences are
not composed of amputees but everybody
has that thing for them you know whether
it's whether it's something physically
obvious or something you know from their
background or their emotional state or a
developmental disability everybody has
you know that thing that they're sort of
insecure about that name that they are
they're dealing with and so to hear a
story hopefully from someone who's like
who's been through something like that
and has come out relatively well on the
other side was and is a story that that
seems to help people and and that's why
I have the privilege of having that job
right and you've done quite a bit of it
and you know I think my suspicion is
that when you do motivational speaking
that you probably get called in to lots
of different environments where you find
yourself I'm speaking to like this
convention for whatever like yeah didn't
they get weird yeah what are some of the
weird places that you found yourself
speaking yeah no yeah I would say maybe
interesting which it would be the
positive spin I put on it but yeah but
you're right it's it's really
interesting that just just because I you
know some types of speakers might be an
expert on something like leadership or
teamwork or whatever but because I'm
just sort of like a life story speaker
you know I talk about my life story and
I apply sort of lessons about overcoming
adversity and try to relate to that to
what individuals in that particular
audience might be going through because
that's a pretty universal message I have
the privilege of speaking to a really
wide range of groups so yeah I mean like
I spoke to a group of cowboys like two
months ago like literally callable like
they are literally Cowboys in Wyoming or
something
North Dakota yeah I mean I was the like
the only person I felt uncomfortable
because I wasn't wearing a cowboy hat
and did not have cowboy boots like that
was the first time in my life would've
been like wow I'm I feel weird because
I'm the only one without the cowboy you
addressed that yeah yeah yeah I like to
acknowledge like those sorts of things
yeah and they were good they had a good
sense of humor about it but you know
like one of the weirdest ones and I
didn't actually end up speaking to them
but I was really hoping I would because
I thought this would be just hilarious
it was like a convention of the what
would you call it like the tanning booth
industry association and I was just like
okay like I'm I'll definitely speak to
you guys and like that's cool but like I
mean you guys
have a thing that causes the disease yet
I had like it just doesn't seem like
yeah yeah yeah it just seems like you
find it yeah like I I mean you know
within moderation ten I'm not judging
people who go to tanning beds it's fine
I just like if I was playing that
convention I wouldn't be like let's get
that guy like if you know if I was like
right if we were like a smoking
convention or whatever or like you know
we sold we're philip morris like we
wouldn't be like let's find a guy who's
overcome lung cancer yeah right you know
it's like it seems like I'm not the
person that you want so yeah but it's uh
it's yeah it's really interesting just
sort of like the the wide variety of
groups I get to speak to at what point
did YouTube start to enter equation and
I'm curious what how does that fit into
the puzzle of what you're doing how do
you view your YouTube presence my first
real like YouTube video was when I was
actually here in LA at USC I was in grad
school and yeah I had no idea what a
vlog was and I I just I really didn't
have I was I was in grad school and you
know it's very different being grad
school you don't necessarily like make
friends or have a social experience or
maybe actually that's problems for what
for communications okay makes sense yeah
I guess I don't know nobody is ever like
for a speech ever been like but do you
have a degree in communication so like
pretty sure that was a waste of money
but whatever it was fine so uh yeah I
was I and I I just had like this I had
had this like really wild experience
which is actually it's in this is not a
a plug but I'm gonna go ahead and make
it a plug I could apply it's in my new
book we should hang out sometime but it
to it
so yeah well I because the book is about
I had never had a girlfriend when I was
like I was like 25 years old and I tried
to date grows a lot and and I had these
sort of like one or two date
relationships and people are always like
Josh I mean you've seen you're not like
too creepy
and we assume you're not like a serial
killer or anything like why have you
never had a girlfriend and I was like I
really
no I have theories but I don't know so I
went back in like investigated by which
I mean I found like all the girls going
like starting in middle school that I
tried to date and I would like have
coffee with them or even physically
found them
yeah and had a physical face-to-face
conversation face-to-face you had an
auditory conversation words yeah what
this is quite a quest yeah it was a
great idea for a book
yeah well and and I will I'm proud to
say that I didn't do it like for Ibaka
yeah
it was it wasn't like it was and maybe
that's just even more weird that I was
just like here's here's a personal
development project I'd like to do it
was only like later that I was I was
kind of like you know this this is this
could be a book this is kind of funny
now now actually now that I have a
girlfriend and there's a happy ending as
okay once I determined that so uh yeah
so I had this experience where there was
a scroll that was trying to date and she
was actually a contestant in Miss
America and and you're on the right
track so far yeah so I want to be clear
like she was Miss North Dakota right
yeah don't you know that why'd we do
research for this yeah that's impressive
yeah that's the one well and because in
you were you just spoke to some cowboys
in North Dakota in North Dakota quite a
bit I - yeah I didn't think there were
any humans there yeah you've been there
at least twice so it's I've spoken in
North Dakota a weirdly large amount I
actually like calculate at once like the
I like North Dakota's population is
shockingly small 600,000 people in the
whole state and there was a time when I
had spoken there so often that I had
spoken to like a multi multiple
percentage points of the entire state it
was like three to four percent of the
state population I had spoken to so
that's how I met Miss North Dakota and
and so yeah we were we were sort of
talking and this is was at USC and so
she was going to be at mystical or she
was gonna be a Miss America which was in
Vegas and so I got like a ticket through
some finagling to like this like
act I gala where I knew she was gonna be
and I was gonna like surprise her and
stuff and you were you had not dated at
this point or I had you she and I
what was your status I would say we were
talking well you know we both like
talked on the phone but yeah I mean yeah
there had been no there have been no
like physical conversations to use your
turn okay I'll put it that way yeah so
but you're gonna surprise her yeah I was
just good yeah I was gonna surprise her
you know I'd seen somebody like rom-coms
or I'd seen I will say enough rom-coms
to know that a grand romantic gesture
like this is you know always is gonna go
well yeah this couldn't fail like
there's no way it could fail and of
course it failed horribly like I mean
like it failed like so horribly was just
like anticlimactically weird like I like
I was like you know she was like kind of
like walking by me and I was like like I
guess I and I didn't really have
anything your mouth your eyes got big
yeah I just shook yeah really yeah
that's pretty much have I I guess I just
imagined she was gonna be like oh like
you're here we're in love let's date
like I'm your girlfriend now I don't
really know what I thought that didn't
happen what really happened was she was
like but you didn't tell me you were
gonna be here and I was like it's a
surprise yeah yeah that was yeah it's a
surprise yes exactly
that was like sort of the point and and
then she was like okay like I have to go
like who's she what she did have to like
go walk in this procession or something
and that was the whole conversation and
we didn't talk was this before the
ceremony a pageant or yeah this is the
night before before yeah
and so there was no follow-up
conversation I guess no nothing not for
like four months
yeah that was just the end because I was
I was like well maybe she'll text maybe
she'll call no nothing so yeah so that
was one of the ones for the book when
years later I wanted to be like so like
remember that time when I showed up to
your pageant so that was really
interesting but this is we're on like so
many levels deeper of stories here let's
finish that one out so yeah on your
quest in the book walk us through
I'm seeking her out yeah you you met up
with her again yeah and and we actually
had like a face-to-face conversation how
did you and I was giving a speech in
North Dakota
obviously when you were passing of
course my my stomping grounds why where
I often show up to give speeches and you
put the tux back on yeah yeah no I was
speaking at a bank you know like to some
employees at a bank and it was like the
town she was in like in a vault like I
mean I pictured behind the teller window
to a bank I mean it was like a gathering
of employees of the bay was it like
watching Bank customers yeah I have
given some weird speeches like that and
I've learned to be like I ask a lot of
questions now before I agree to show up
to make sure I'm not gonna be in that
like one time I spoke to it what I
thought was gonna be a group of army
vets who had lost legs or arms and I was
like this is great like I'd love to like
her for these guys and it turns out I
was actually just speaking at a
cafeteria in a hotel near an Army
Hospital - whoo - anyone who happened to
be in the cafeteria I kid you not no
advertising it was just people who were
just happened to be getting food and I
would just they were just yeah just go
just like stand in the middle room start
talking now I I was like are you serious
oh yeah that's a whole no destroy what
happened there it was just it was
horrible like it was so bad like it paid
no I was volunteering like I thought I
was helping army vets
was it in North Dakota oh yeah that
speech was so bad it was
yeah they had like there was a TV on
they wouldn't turn the TV off it's like
oh my gosh I mean that was that was
probably the worst speech ever it
fortunately has never gotten better
worse than that to it now I'm very
careful to ask why I like it so this is
an event like that people are going to
unpermitted yes like they know I'm gonna
be there okay so Miss North Dakota you
you triangulated where she was gonna be
and yes intersected with you giving a
talk yeah I'd like to like make it sound
creepy than that like I wasn't like
triangulating herself oh and be like
okay I see her coordinates I this is
where she is I will show up there I
contacted her and invited her to come to
my speech okay and we're like yeah
that's like you know get food afterwards
and and and yeah so I and by this time
yeah I I was sort of more yeah well it
was an interesting conversation because
I we talked and and she was kind of like
I'm loving this by the way because she
was uh yes she we like obviously
remembered the situation you know the me
showing up and and was really impressed
that I was there because the the gala
that I was attending was supposed to be
two thousand dollars a plate I got a
ticket because I gave a free speech in
into a cafeteria someone yeah it was
weird but totally worth it and so first
she was just so she'd like so which to
me made it even crazier like she was
like she thought I had spent $2,000 to
see her was like wait why you didn't
text me like what what happened right
and so cuz I at the time I thought well
maybe she has a boyfriend that just
entered the picture or something like
that but uh yeah so it was basically
like a really interesting lesson for me
and sort of empathy and like looking at
something from another person's
perspective because for her it's like
the biggest moment of her life right you
know she's been preparing this literally
for this moment for years and she's very
focused on the competition and this guy
like just shows up and she's very like
befuddled and confused and just like
literally doesn't know what to say
and then the competition happens and she
didn't like do as well as she wanted and
then so she was like you like a little
like an embarrassed you know like that
maybe felt like she'd kind of like lat
because you know she added the friends
and family there and she felt like she
kind of like lied everyone down a little
bit and and and and so it was you know
that's where she was coming from and I
was coming from just sort of a place of
insecurity where I was like oh if she
didn't like text me immediately
afterward she must not like me I'm never
gonna talk to her again
yeah you know and
and and she was like yeah but I was like
really disappointed you know you didn't
contact me afterwards because like I was
so into you and like what like wait hold
on like you really like you know so so
then I was like what comes crystal clear
that you really did blow it yeah that it
was crystal clear
speaking of crystal
it was Sunnah and I was beginning to get
thoughts in this conversation like well
maybe know that we've come figured this
out never yeah but it just so happens
that approximately six weeks before this
particular dinner she got engaged and
had a diamond ring so that's what what
the book is about but yeah so each so
each chapter is a different or a
different girl yeah so it's a there's
like six I actually tracked down 12
girls and six of them are in the book
some of them were like just not
interesting enough for the book or there
wasn't like a it wasn't I don't know
just not you can't fit everything there
was like more stories and you know your
editor always wants to cut stuff out so
there's a cool yeah b-side girl says
would you call that one so just to go
back for a second
we took the detour from you getting into
YouTube right from so you were at USC
yes so yeah so I so I had this
experience I'll give you the abbreviated
version of the story while I was in when
I was getting ready or you know I was at
the at the black-tie gala and I don't
like you guys have probably have you
ever won about like a real bowtie before
not a real bow tie I'm afraid of that
mmm you know I have won it ties around
yeah yeah like and you have to tie I
didn't dye it okay yeah so this feel
like that would be a good him when he my
goodness oh dust trying to do this like
as a challenge because it's freaking
impossible
okay they're always crooked and like
uneven or lopsided so I was in the men's
room you know trying to like it all
spiffed before my like big grand gesture
when she saw me and and I was you know
I'm it's like worried about my boat I am
but it's like it's so hard to tie right
I'm just like I can't get it I was
really frustrated yeah and I was like
man you know the next time I wear a real
or the next time I wear a bow
I'm gonna do like a like a clip-on you
know like what you wear to prom it's
like pre-tied because I was like a real
bowtie is just not worth it like that
was the phrase in my mind I was like
this is not worth it and and this this
guy walked in and just part of like
having one leg is that people strangers
for some reason feel a certain subset of
the population feels just a just like
they have the right to like say anything
they want you to inquire about your
medical history or or or they feel even
just a need to say something about how
you have a disability okay so this guy
who walks in and he's like because I was
like kind of balancing at the mirror
like working my bow tie he's like oh it
looks like you do pretty well with that
but but I was so focused on my bow to
those two hands you have yeah but I was
like I was so focused on my bowtie and
like I don't you know I talk a lot about
hugging one leg in my speeches and
videos and stuff but I don't like
necessarily actively think all the time
like I'm an amputee this is my
perspective so like I wasn't really
thinking like I thought he meant he my
bowtie so I was like oh thank you like
you know I appreciate that and and and
this is like the totally true story so
we uh we then we go over like to the
urinals
I get like I guess I only like gave up
sore or came to a satisfactory point and
my bow tying and we're so we're both
standing at the urinals kind of near by
each other and I was like uh yeah you
know I'm still thinking about my bow tie
and he's like still thinking presumably
about my life situation and I was like
I'll tell you though it's actually
pretty difficult got the bow tie whoa we
are peeing and the dude is like yeah
like it looks like it would be pretty
difficult and then I said I kid you not
I was like in fact tonight I've been
feeling like it's just not even worth
[Laughter]
his pee stream stopped yeah exactly yeah
he's like you know making icon
number one rule of social interaction
new urinals yeah yeah
he's like he's like son it's always
worth it and I was like I was really in
the bowtie yeah I was like I didn't
think I was that good at tiny but maybe
I'm better than I thought and like and
so it literally didn't hit me till like
weeks later I'm sitting in my dorm room
at USC and I was like oh like that's why
he was so like dramatic and like worried
for me thought like I was talking about
my life not being worth it and and so
I'm sitting in my like one room you know
my single at USC and I was just like I
have to tell someone about this story
and I had a webcam and I was like maybe
I could just like record this into the
webcam and put it on the Internet and I
did and that was my first vlog and were
you hoping that that guy would see it
yeah I mean dude at the urinal this I
assume that yeah he's like probably out
there like you know having prayer vigils
you know like I met this this depressed
one-legged man was destiny he's open
right up to his ropes yeah pouring his
heart out as he peed yeah so that was
how I started on YouTube it I didn't
that was early on it was like yeah yeah
that was a long time ago that was o8 and
I had a couple videos on my channel that
were just like demos of me speaking okay
and I didn't really make any videos that
didn't you know I got like I really
didn't even know what a vlog was I
didn't know that I had made a vlog and
it wasn't until 2010 when my first book
came out just don't fall that to promote
that I made a video called the amputee
wrap and and then that video did really
really well and that's and and you know
and people were like it was it was it
was kind of like people were like way
more excited about that than the book
and and I was like I worked for years on
this book and two weeks on the video you
should read the book but but I saw then
just like then I started like looking at
youtubers and like seeing guys like you
guys and like finding out like oh
there's this whole world out there of
YouTube and like what would happen I and
I looked like scroll back and was like
oh my gosh this like urinal story I told
years ago has thousands of views now
like I could keep doing that
and so yeah that's like I just kept
making vlogs after that so what how does
your YouTube channel fit and what your
into your puzzle at this point yeah
that's a really good question and one
that I spend a lot of time thinking
about it is yeah does it is it just to
drive business to speaking or does it
have life in a business of its own
you're trying to there's a tension there
I guess yeah I think of YouTube mostly
as a really intense hobby like I don't
may you know like I don't have enough
subscribers that I could make a living
off of it or anything like that so so
mostly mostly from me it's just I really
like making videos and telling stories
into a camera and and it's really fun
that said it is a component like if if I
were to explain my career to people I
would say I give speeches I give
motivational speeches I write books and
I make youtube videos and I think there
is a really nice symbiosis to all of
those sure most of my income comes from
speaking but a lot of the speaking
requests come because people saw a
YouTube video or because they read a
book and the book sales come because
people saw me speak or they saw a
YouTube video and and and so it you know
it all works you know and it's like it
all kind of it all kind of works
together I guess in that sense well
would it be a spoiler alert to ask you
know what is what's the ultimate
takeaway from from the book mmm-hmm no
yes I mean would read the book for the
take home no I mean I think I mean
obviously I'm engaged so the big spoiler
of course is like watch it in the end of
the book I was just dating my girlfriend
so okay you wouldn't know that from
reading that that we are engaged now but
yeah I know I think you know with each
girl I learned a little bit something
different so you know there was there
was sort of like one you know one lesson
was about maybe like about like sort of
empathy like what we talked about with
the Miss America contestant or one
lesson might be about you know not
always like assuming sort of like the
worst you know not assuming like because
she said this oh she must hate me like
maybe there's another reasonable
explanation but the overall thing that I
think I took
where was this that I went into it the
investigation assuming that I had never
had a girlfriend because there was
something wrong with me and what I
realized was actually there had just
been a lot of just kind of unlucky
situations and if there was anything
wrong with me it was that assumption
it was thinking that there was something
wrong with me in other words it was like
having that insecurity that doubt that
like thinking oh there's there's
something like inadequate about me right
because you know like that's like that's
like the the least attractive thing in a
person right but the most attractive
person by contrast is someone who's like
who is confident in who they are like
flaws and all they're like this is who I
am I accept myself as who I am and I
think like that's what makes you a
tremendously attractive person to
someone that you might be interested in
dating right
and how did your fiance feel about all
the stories about all the ladies yeah
she I definitely like talked to her a
lot about it you know before before it
became a book just to like make sure she
was gonna be cool with it and I think
she was really pleased to be the happy
ending of the book like I think like an
early please that you were such an idiot
all along yeah yeah yeah I think yeah I
think she's like yeah is kind enough to
think that she's very lucky that the
other girls didn't discover me or
something but but yeah you know I think
I think she loves and and rightly so and
I'm glad that she does you know being
that that she's like the person at the
end who sort of like it's like I finally
found someone and it's her right what
stands out as one of the best responses
you've gotten I'm sure there's a lot of
people who come up and want to talk to
you mm-hmm
whenever you speak and what stands out
as one of the stupidest things like you
talk about the people who just have to
say something and then I'll see if I can
top both okay so as far as like after
giving a speech yeah there's gotta be
anything you've done in public I imagine
the rewarding moment of someone wanting
to you've opened up
and inspired yeah it's someone they want
to give back someone said imagine
there's been a lot of people saying
great things to you oh yeah so I mean
yeah you know so many amazing things and
that's certainly like one of the coolest
and most rewarding parts of the job you
know is being able to do something that
I really enjoy like performing and
sharing my story and that I get to do it
professionally and that's something that
helps people yeah so I mean so many
things I you know I think I guess
probably the most poignant example would
be a a girl came up to me and one of my
early speeches that was at when I was
not really even a good speaker came up
to me like gave me a like a suicide
prevention hotline card and was like you
know like thanks to you like I feel like
I don't need this anymore and that meant
a lot to me
and so as far as sort of the flip side
man yeah I've really heard it all I you
know it's like people people after you
give a speech because they've just heard
you and and you guys probably relate to
this as youtubers like you know when you
meet someone and they're kind of like
wait what why aren't you doing a YouTube
video for me right now like if you ask
them a question or if there's like a
pause they're like hold what what why
are you not why are you not where the
jump cuts like you know yeah and so you
know people kind of come to you after
the speech and they're just kinda like
where's where's my motivational speech
like why why are you not speaking why do
you not can't it why are you not telling
long stories with jokes right now yeah
and that's that's weird but yeah people
will will relate yeah it's like I don't
I hate to like belittle people's
problems you know but they'll be like I
understand what it's like to have one
leg because and then and then just say
you know like how are they gonna go with
this but but you know and sometimes
people you know have like a really
serious problem but but it you know like
it'll be like a again like I had to be
like trivial but it'll be like something
you know just something really like you
know because yeah oftentimes me were
like because like I sprained my ankle
last year and I was on crutches for two
weeks so like I totally get like what
you've gone through
I'm like oh cool look I'm glad I'm sure
you're always gracious yeah I try to be
nice I'm like I cool like I'm not trying
yeah it's a little different Oh what I'm
glad that it spoke to you yeah I don't
know if I want a I don't know if I wanna
so body top that well I mean don't you
don't have to top it but but I share
your what what are what are some
meaningful and really strange things
people said to you oh no I was gonna try
to be one of those people and ask it's
gonna be like story time which they know
where you're going with that if I could
ask something even stupid oh yeah people
of that oh man oh if you want talk about
stupid questions Wow
like I mean just in trance what I mean
just pure questions yes how about this
one what what did they do with the leg
after they get rid of it yeah I don't
think that's a stupid question
and that's something that I would be
curious about I mean well I mean I kind
of know they like they like study it too
like because you know just for like sort
of case history information to know oh
like how did because it's a rare form of
cancer right so it's like they want to
know like how much did it spread into
the muscle and they learn like it's bad
a lot of big mistake say hey do you want
a one last look or is that usually when
it's on you that's the last look for you
personally yeah no I didn't have
anything like that I've heard of
amputees like keeping their like
fingernails or toenails I didn't like
ask for that kind of macabre yeah it
seemed a little weird to me and I feel
like eventually you you would inevitably
come to some ceremony where you're like
I'm going to like throw these into the
ocean because I've moved on you know so
so yeah yeah if you wanted to take the
leg they wouldn't have let you do it
probably I should hope not
Dennis won't let you take a tooth yeah
yeah you should hope that they would not
allow you to walk out with an actual
limb but yeah I'll give you some stupid
questions that people have asked me and
these are the really stupid questions
are typically not after a speech and I
think the reason is because I make fun
of in my speeches a lot of times I talk
about stupid questions that people ask
that no people are a little like I don't
want to learn his in the next speech so
the the stupid questions are inevitably
just people who walk up to me on the
side
so or just you know casual conversations
so maybe my all-time list would be I was
talking to this girl about my artificial
leg which I was wearing I still wore
like this was in high school
we're talking about how it worked and
you know everybody has questions about
artificial legs and and she was like oh
so is the foot fake too
really yeah really like totally serious
I like I don't know like I just don't
even know how like what the like and I
was like oh you know it's funny you ask
like the doctors actually took my real
bullet and attached it on the end of my
artificial leg but fake - yeah oh my
yeah like I don't even know like how
could she imagine that that was yeah we
there's like a Frankenstein system she
doesn't understand blood supply yeah
it's like yeah we there's blood running
through the fake leg to nourish the like
yeah I mean oh wow yeah so that happened
I had a guy pretty recently maybe a year
ago now I live just outside Washington
DC and he was in my neighborhood I was
walking on the sidewalk and I you know I
was on my crotches no no prosthesis and
he like taps me on the shoulder of
course because I have one like he so he
needs to talk to me about it and just
his opening line he's like so how come
you don't have a prostate how could you
tell here's the other hand to you
did you know this information and then I
figured out like like what he meant at
Beau's like me that is not the kind of
cancer that I had actually it was bone
cancer yeah and just just in terms of
sheer stupidity on my third date with
Ashley so this was like you know pretty
new relationship and we're at don't
throw your fiance under the bus
oh no this is not a question she asked
okay guy though she has s what's about I
was gonna save you from that one oh they
know she's asked some pretty for some
pretty good questions pretty good
questions ready put it pretty good yeah
we'll put it that way person yeah
no no she was just she was she was there
to witness it I'm just I'm trying to
raise the stakes of the story because
it's like we're nervous one initial date
and so we were eating dessert it was
sort of like a dessert bar you know and
so so she was sitting beside me on one
side and there was this guy sitting
beside me another side like you know
never really wants to talk about one leg
and all this situation like this is like
a grown man I just want to be very clear
I don't think he was like intoxicated or
anything and he was like you know he was
like so like how long is it gonna take
before you know and I was like no no I
don't know actually like what no what do
you ask me you're a starfish and yes and
he was like I kid you not he's like how
long is it gonna take for your leg to
grow back and I was like are you serious
right now like yeah exactly like do you
think do I look like a starfish what do
I look like a lizard like I can just
spontaneously regrow appendages like it
was just how how does someone get to
adulthood right at like oh yeah just
wanna world what what in his life
experience had like indicated to him
maybe he had he maybe he had one grow
back that that was like you take you I
don't I took five years
right but yeah but no the hilarious
thing was I mean cuz I think he would
genuinely with sincere Syrah and this is
this is why I believe that because after
that he got a lot more serious and he
was like oh man
and he's like can I buy you a drink yes
thank you this is a great solution I can
turn to alcohol yep to like help me feel
better about how my leg is not gonna
grow back and buy your drinks huh yeah
I'll buy you a drink is that leg ain't
coming back you should have just said
we'll just grab and pull right here and
there probably well I don't know we
didn't even get into it but people can
read your first book just don't fall we
will you were a skier that's right yeah
for a long time there's quite a lot we
could talk to you forever yeah that's my
story we can throw people to your books
you know more stories about the the
encounters of the ladies and we should
hang out sometime in more stories about
your life and your background and just
don't fall and you know a lot of stories
on your youtube channel which people can
check out too yeah we truly appreciate
being able to hang out and get to know
you and thanks for allowing us to ask
all the questions that we asked some of
those may rank up there no those are
awesome questions that no it's it's an
honor to be here and so fun hanging out
with you guys
[Music]
and there you have it our year biscuit
with Josh Sundquist let him know what
you think by tweeting at him his Twitter
handle is Josh Sundquist there's a D in
there yeah I always make sure to say the
d qu ist Sundquist it's not Sundquist
like sun-kissed it's Sundquist hashtag
ear biscuits and also make sure that you
watch our song biscuit mm-hmm
with Josh and and check out his in his
book we should hang out sometime
dot-com that's the way it's done these
days you write a book and then you name
a website that's the same thing as the
blog where you can get it we should hang
out sometime calm maybe we should write
a book maybe we should do the same thing
is such a good idea we could get his
permission first we go track down our
ex-girlfriends well the interesting
thing is a few of them are the same girl
yes a couple of chapters it would be the
crossover chapters is what we would call
those Leslie and amber but the thing is
I I think we know what went wrong with
with Leslie that led to each of our
breakup so we didn't talk to her you
know I don't need to write a book about
that yeah I just didn't I didn't know
how to speak to her yeah and great I was
afraid of her with amber I don't know I
think with you probably ended the same
way you didn't know how to manage a
relationship I think I had a real
relationship there could be a chapter
there with amber yeah I'll write the
amber chapter you can offer commentary
and like this will do a thing where when
one guy's writing the other guy writes
in the margins but it's part of the book
who are we kidding we've talked about
our ex-girlfriend so much that there's
we can't write a book I mean you've
heard it all people I mean so instead of
you buying a book from us about our
ex-girlfriends we're just gonna remind
you to take the pod survey calm slash
biscuits survey again that takes five
minutes thanks for listening this long
you're a true listener you're still
listening to us and like we said it will
really help us out to find out what
you're truly interested in let's line up
some advertisers that makes sense for
both of us so that you don't have to pay
for this podcast yeah because if it
doesn't work we're gonna start charging
what are we thinking about charging
$1,000 per download is that what it is
yeah that's the price point yes yeah so
per person you know either that or go to
pop star area
expensive I know you like this that
would be very expensive slash pissed
that would be like a salary a year per
person just to listen to this podcast
and you don't want that to happen
alright so this the air biscuit is
winding down you can hear the music back
there so just go ahead and pull up that
you know Apple tea browser window not
what's their own Windows machine
whatever that is Apple W I think there's
an actual window instead of an apple
it's like a window that's flying through
the air pod survey dot-com slash biscuit
pods birthday biscuit Tom slash biscuit
more than one this within it yeah
pod survey dot-com slash biscuits
[Music]
[Music]